- De l'attente, toujours pluet s
beaucoup d'aéroportsaux quatreùe
de personnel cause des retards
depuis ds.
"Ce qui ci n'est pas
normal. C'est un vrai drame",
dit Amy Mingels.
L'étudia.
"J'espère qu'il y aura bientôt
une solution et qut profitert pr
de leurs vacances
après e.
En Suède aussi, les voyage
Ici, c'est une grève des pilotes
qui cloue les avio
Esther et Clara devaient prendre
l'avion à Göteborg.
Un vol local qui a finalement
été annulé à la dernière minute.
"On va devoir rentrer à la
maison et prendre
ça devait être l'été de la
reprise", a déploré un patronde.
Une tentative d'apaisement,
car la colère des passagers
les compagnies aériennes.d'Easyé
après avoir été blâmé
pour l'annulation
de centaines de vols.
Et aux États-Unis aussi, s'élèr
demander des comptes
des compagnies aériennes.
public et elles doivent
livrer la marchandise",
a martelé le secrétaire
aux Transports Pete Buttigieg.
Car les aéroports américainset ,
cette passagère n'est toujours
arrivée à destination.qui résumt
de beaucoup de voyageurs,
alors que la haute saison
s'annonce de plus en plus haute
en stress et en imprévus.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Tor